I knew we would be perfect together
and i was right
Welcome back everyone this will be
my full halo episode 1 video there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs to break down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing videos for all the episodes
depending on how everybody feels about the series
just in general how everyone feels about all the
episodes so careful for spoilers if you have not
seen halo episode 1 yet we'll go through scene
by scene talking about easter eggs wtf moments
there will be a couple things that i probably will
not cover like the true purpose of the halo rings
exactly who the forerunners are their relationship
with the ancient humans or the progenitors
there's so much to unpack in this first episode
it was basically just a tutorial for people who
had never seen halo before ever in their lives
or had never played any of the video game series
so the waiting a couple episodes kind of give
you the entire backstory but the tagline for
the series is win the halo ring win the war so
by the finale the goal will be to find the halo
ring and gain control of it before the covenant
do the one they believe is the only halo ring
even though there are several halo rings around
the galaxy like i said the lore goes really deep
but starting with the episode title episode 1
was titled contact it was a reference to master
chief making contact with the forerunners
making physical contact and mental contact
with the forerunner artifact the contact
he makes with a human survivor like quan ha
the contact that he literally makes with the
covenant elites the opening scene is the sans
madrigal madrigal as a planet was referenced in
halo's myth series a couple of games including
the contact harvest coal protocol halo 3 odst it
started out as an easter egg in the games actually
but then was made canon when they officially
published the halo contact harvest in 2007.
the tv show as you can tell like they talk
about the master chiefs team the silver team
silver time is a reference to the show existing
in an alternate timeline of the video game canon
as you can see they made some changes in
the name of practicality and getting on air
this caused it to deviate from established video
game canon so it's being viewed internally as an
alternate timeline for instance master chief
is never or rarely but essentially never
seen with his helmet off any scene during this
episode taking his helmet off some of the larger
changes you notice when they show the covenant
assembly at high charity high charity being
their mobile planetoid station it's the reason
the united space command aren't able to locate
them at the beginning of the series because the
covenant is able to move their base of operations
you only get a brief glimpse of high charity in
this episode but the covenant is a collection of
alien species held together by their religious
belief in the forerunners it's a religious war
that they think they're fighting the colony news
broadcast is complaining about reach seeking to
enslave the colonist's population reaches like
the next biggest unsc occupied world and base next
to planet earth within the inner colonies all the
mobilization you see all the tech all the hardware
you see the unsc spartans roll out comes from
reach so reach is like the powers that be it's
also the birthplace of the spartan 2 program
which produced master chief and his fellow
spartans the silver team here the place where you
see dr catherine halsey in her lab all the time
the reason the spartans were created in the
first place was because the unsc wanted their own
version of super soldiers enhanced by biology and
mechanical methods they beef up their bodies while
they're young then they pair them with a superior
exoskeleton suit like you see master chief and
the rest of his team wear like he tells quan huh
there's no way you're gonna be able to fire your
way through this i'll have to take my helmet off
before you can fire an actual bullet that'll kill
me there'd been a lot of civil war amongst their
outer colonies like the old timer mentions at the
card game his hands were dirty awash in the blood
of unsc marines the spartan program was started
because the unsc needed a quick effective way of
putting down rebellion with as few lives lost as
possible and they were tired of throwing regular
marines at the problem thus various versions of
the program were implemented until they got to the
spartan 2 program and you see master chief and his
team before you the ironic thing like you have
a surviving colonist like one surviving colonist
from this place here is it the spartan 3 program
the successor to the spartan 2 program the master
chiefs program was mostly populated by children of
dead colonists because they thought it was cheaper
catherine halsey and the unsc who enabled her
experience aren't necessarily viewed as good
people like the actress natasha mcelhin plays her
a little ambiguously very curious very determined
in the name of science of progress but the
detriment of something else but as you learned
they essentially stole a lot of children that were
part of master chief's group of kids experimenting
on them a lot died some survive the training to
become like master chief until you get the perfect
weapon the problem that they have at unsc command
then is when master chief comes into contact with
the forerunner tech he finds it and interacts with
it and it sort of scrambles the programming they
had built into him the broadcaster here venture
grath is played by bern gorman who a bunch of
you recognize from torchwood or somewhere else
recently because he's a fairly popular actor
they reference the jin ha character who's the
leader of the rebel insurgency on this colony
opposition force that's standing against the unsc
even though he's only in the episode for a couple
minutes it's really his daughter quan ha who
becomes the more important character she's one
of the newer additions to the narrative normally
in halo games you either take the master chief's
perspective like the main spartans perspective or
you take the arbiter or the covenant's perspective
you only see glimpses of other viewpoints
other storylines that take place concurrently
like the catherine halsey storyline or the flood
storyline you learn about that in snippets and
in cutscenes but you spend all your time in one
of those two perspectives the difference in the
tv show is that they'll take a couple different
viewpoints since this is the first episode it's
mostly just a halo tutorial like i said but
they are careful to reference why madrigal is
so important such a high value colony to the unsc
which they use for all their fuel all their drugs
powers pretty much everything at this point they
haven't quite learned about forerunner tech yet
then the covenant attacks looking for what the
colonists haven't realized is a local cachet of
forerunner tech the reason the covenant forces
seek to steal or take or seal off any forerunner
tech from anyone or kill anyone they find using
it is because they view it as sacred only humanity
was deemed by the forerunners to be worthy of
being their successor in the milky way galaxy
all the different races of the covenant evolved
without the genetic programming needed to operate
forerunner tech or activated in any functional
way but they worship it and they worship the
forerunners as gods they view protecting
forerunner artifacts as their sacred duty in
future episodes you also see that they keep a few
humans one in particular maki this character here
who they refer to as a reclaimer literally helping
them reclaim and activate forerunner artifacts
because unlike them she's a humanoid which is
another big change from the video game series
the special effects that they use for the sangheli
are okay they could be better they kind of size
them up a little bit to make them seem more
brutish more indestructible next to the regular
humans to better show off the master chiefs
and the spartans abilities when they roll in
as they say the covenant forces literally think of
them as demons like actual literal demons because
for them it's religious war as you can tell one of
the things they worked hardest on was getting the
armor video game accurate along with the weapons
as well the shield recharge is particularly
familiar for anyone who's played the game everyone
of course knows john 117 aka master chief by the
side of him john 117 was a designation given to
him when he was taken from his family as a child
which you see several times in flashbacks
throughout the episode once he hits the
ground though and starts killing a bunch of the
covenant forces then they hit you with the intro
title scene which depicts the spartan 2 program
creation of master chief you see him slowly as
they experiment on his body then they develop
the exoskeleton around him the music has echoes
of the classic halo music but it's meant to be
new it sounds a little bit more like the classic
halo theme song during the end of the episode as
you see them go around and kill the rest of the
colonists though the reason the covenant are here
in the first place the reason why they're trying
to kill the colonists is because they think
they've interacted with the forerunner tech
nearby in the cave which master chief only learns
about later they spot the type 52 phantom that
the covenant used for their low numbers drop
ships is not meant to carry a ton of soldiers
but that's where master chief and the silver team
find the 4runner tech in the caves the reason the
4runner tech activates for master chief is because
he's human it would have turned on for any human
who had touched it it's because forerunners
made it so that humans would eventually be
able to find and use their technology for many
many reasons which i won't get into this video
because i don't want to turn into an hour-long
dissertation on the history of the halo universe
but it triggers a flashback to his repressed
childhood memories something we really don't
get in a lot of the games just hinting at his
past before he was abducted by catherine halsey
in the spartan 2 program and he was abducted as a
child like he didn't go with them willingly back
at reach they show the main city and catherine
halsey's lab as she views the forerunner tech
the point they at during this series foreigner
tech is only a myth to them but they don't really
understand how important it will be to them to
utilize it but catherine halsey thinks that this
artifact this forerunner artifact might be the
key to them winning their war against the covenant
that's why she's so interested in it but at this
point human command don't know anything about the
foreigners the covenant's relationship with them
the covenant's relationship with humanity and the
holy war that they feel like they're fighting the
miranda that they mention is miranda keys within
the unsc forces whose catherine halsey's daughter
with her husband captain jacob keys who you meet
later in the episode obviously for the purposes
of this series they've been aged down quite a bit
the development she's talking about includes
things like cloning and cortana which they
reveal later another piece of classic halo
lore from the games everyone will remember
cortana is probably the second most important
character on the show cortana being like the ai
intended to be the spartans partners in all their
endeavors like a true partner only in digital form
the cloning is the questionable morality that i
talked about in order to create cortana the ai
and all the other spartans she essentially creates
flash clones clones that are grown super fast
and harvests their brains when they become mature
enough in order to serve as the bases for ai that
would become cortana for master chief and for the
others but that's why it's her in the cloning tank
she's creating cortana based on her own brain for
master chief issues that cortana will be played by
a different character but it'll be based on her
brain we get a brief look at high charity the
covenant's mobile planetoid in the name of the
hierarchy is the high prophet of mercy he's one
of the three hierarchs who reside over the council
that governs all the actions within the covenant
who's keeping what looks like a human reclaimer as
a pet so to speak they're calling her maki but she
is a human if that wasn't clear because she asked
to speak with master chief after he activated
the 4runner artifact they'll probably have the
covenant capture him at some point during the
season and he'll learn more about its true purpose
and learn about the halo ring's true purpose they
show captain jacob keys who's much younger than
you remember probably during the video game series
they talk about their mutual love of catherine
halsey despite how she is focused more on her work
how she keeps getting miranda keys from
getting promoted with any chance of real danger
she eventually does lead her own command when she
gets older the article 72 twist this should show
human command is just as bad as covenant command
is is providing this gray area for master chief
and cortana eventually to operate in not totally
trusting unsc command not totally trusting the
covenant forces either quan ha asking master chief
if he ever takes the helmet off is a reference to
him never taking the helmet off in the video game
series although it does foreshadow him taking it
off at the end of the episode which is one of
the stark contrast to the video game series
halsey references cortana by name for the first
time although we probably won't meet her for the
first time until episode 2. the whole thing with
him trying to disable him by disabling the oxygen
is just showing what master chief is capable
of physically but they show the other spartans
armoring up preparing to protect him and fight
the other marines if necessary when they're doing
their big silver team suit up montage the theme
song is somewhat similar to the classic halo theme
music but it's also another way of showing that
halsey is protecting master chief because he has
the artifact if he didn't or he hadn't interacted
with it she probably wouldn't be quite as quick
to use a silver team to kill regular marines
to protect him but him touching the artifact
triggers the flashback for a second time back
to his child reactivates the troop transport
and triggers a reboot cycle for the rest of the
fleet on reach halsey's reaction is probably one
of the more interested ones like she seems more
interested and impressed at the site of what the
foreign artifact can do and wants to study it more
i haven't seen episode two yet but the two of them
master chief and kwan hot are probably headed
for a friendly resupply depot where master chief
can learn more about the artifact and more about
his memories if you spotted any huge easter eggs
during the episode that i didn't mention during
the video please write them in the comments below
there were a billion things that you could talk
about in this video alone like we could talk about
the true purpose of the halo rings but i will
continue doing weekly videos just depending on
how this video does and how everybody feels about
the series in general i feel like hardcore fans
will be a little upset like if it's possible to be
a little upset that it's not completely canon to
the video game series but hopefully they do have
some fun with the rest of the episodes there's
at least potential here for it to be a really fun
series they have renewed it for season 2 as we're
speaking right now but my moon knight episodes will
start next week after they start releasing them so
be sure to enable alerts for my channel to be the
first to watch them click here for my new marvel
secret invasion announcement and click here for my
moon knight episode 1 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!